Hi ihr Lieben! Heute machen wir eine No Bake Torte und zwar eine total zitronige!
Die favorisiere ich jetzt schon! Also ich glaube die werde ich immer und immer wieder machen und ihr genauso.
Die Torte geht super schnell. Wir machen jetzt zuallererst einen No Bake Boden
und dafür habe ich hier schon mal meine Butterkekse.
Die werde ich fein mixen und dann noch geschmolzene Butter hinzufügen.
So und jetzt pimpen wir den Keksboden noch auf, es wird ja eine Zitronentorte.
Und daher benutze ich heute ganz viel Lemon Curd von Chivers.
Das habe ich eigentlich immer im Vorratsschrank weil ich backe damit gerne,
ich schmier' mir das aber auch gerne zum Frühstück aufs Brot, das könnt ihr vielseitig verwenden.
Und da gebe ich jetzt 2 Teelöffel in die Butterkeks-Masse.
Und die ganz genauen Mengenangaben, die findet ihr wie immer hier unten in der Videobeschreibung.
Und mit dem Butterkeksboden ziehen wir dann einen Rand hoch und drücken alles schön fest an.
Ich zum Beispiel nehme dafür am liebsten meinen Silikon Kochhelfer, damit funktioniert das total einfach.
Und jetzt gebe ich das hier erst einmal an die Seite und wir machen weiter mit der Sahne.
Die Sahne kommt ganz frisch aus dem Kühlschrank.
Gerade im Sommer müsst ihr darauf achten, dass sie gekühlt ist.
Ich habe auch meine Schlüssel und meinen Schneebesenaufsatz für 5min in die Kühlung getan
und dann kann euch nichts mehr schief gehen!
So, das gebe ich jetzt mit rein.
Natürlich könnt ihr auch euer Handrührgerät verwenden falls ihr keine Küchenmaschine habt.
So und ich werde das Ganze noch mit Sahnefest ein bisschen besser steifen
und gerade im Sommer auf Sahnefest auch nicht unbedingt verzichten!
So, die Sahne ist steif geschlagen und jetzt habe ich hier noch Magerquark.
Ich finde das passt perfekt, auch zur Zitronentorte, das passt zum Lemon Curd
und die Creme ist einfach ein kleiner Süchtigmacher!
So, da gebe ich jetzt ein bisschen Zucker mit dazu, ein bisschen Vanilleextrakt
weil ich finde auch, dass Vanille und Zitrone immer mega miteinander harmonieren.
So!
Und natürlich unser Lemon Curd.
So von der fertigen Creme jetzt 5 Esslöffel zur Seite legen,
das benutzen wir nämlich später noch für die Deko.
Und jetzt geht es weiter mit Mandarinen. Ich hab mir überlegt damit der Anschnitt auch aufregend ist,
nehmen wir uns jetzt Mandarinen aus der Dose. Die sind ja schon geschält
und die gebe ich jetzt hier einfach auf den Boden. Wichtig ist, dass ihr die gut abtropfen lasst
und dass ihr den Saft aus der Dose nicht wegschüttet.
So, nachdem ihr dann die Creme eingefüllt und glatt gestrichen habt, hier nochmal den Rand säubern.
(H: Wofür?)
Damit gleich wenn der Guss drüberkommt sich das nicht miteinander vermischt.
So ihr Lieben, jetzt geht's schon an den hübschen Guss.
Ich sag hübsch weil der Guss wird richtig schön gelb sein und nach Zitrone schreien!
Ich habe jetzt hier den aufgefangenen Saft von den Mandarinen, den gebe ich hier in meinen Topf.
Der Herd ist noch aus, noch nicht einschalten! So dann geben wir da auch Lemon Curd dazu
natürlich für den Geschmack. Und ihr müsst jetzt nicht zusätzlich gelb färben
denn durch die hübsche Farbe hier färbt sich gleicht das Ganze richtig schön gelb.
So und dann - ganz ganz wichtig - brauchen wir Agar Agar, das ist pflanzliches Geliermittel,
ist 'ne super Alternative zu Gelatine. Gebe ich da jetzt noch mit rein, verrühre das Ganze
und dann koche ich das auf und lasse das  2min lang schön sprudelnd kochen.
So, jetzt habe ich den Guss 10min lang abkühlen lassen
damit er auch nicht ganz so heiß auf die Oberfläche kommt.
Jetzt schnappt ihr euch einen Löffel und gießt das ganz vorsichtig oben drüber.
Und nun muss die Torte gekühlt werden für mindestens 3h.
Ihr könnt das Ganze auch über Nacht vorbereiten und dann habt ihr halt am Vortag ein bisschen Arbeit
und könnt am nächsten Tag die leckere Torte genießen.
So und jetzt werde ich den Tortenring entfernen.
Dafür am besten einen Backformlöser nehmen damit ihr sie jetzt auch nicht zerstört,
das wäre nämlich mega mega schade!
Und dann dekoriere ich noch mit der restlichen Sahne, mit Zitronen und natürlich mit ein bisschen Minze.
(H: Kiki man hat dich nicht gesehen, du musst es noch mal machen!)
Hat man mich nicht gesehen?
Woow! Nein, ich war echt begeistert weil ich wollte es genau so,
dass man noch so ein bisschen die Creme sieht und dann eben der gelbe Abschluss!
So und jetzt dekoriere ich fleißig.
Ta-da! Fertig ist die wunderschöne und erfrischende Lemon Curd Torte.
Und das Ganze ohne Backen und ohne viel Aufwand wie ich finde!
Ich schreibe euch wie gesagt alle ganz genauen Mengenangaben hier unten in die Videobeschreibung.
Ansonsten könnt ihr jetzt natürlich das Glas entweder auslöffeln, aufs Brot schmieren
oder was auch ganz cool ist für den Sommer: ihr könnt daraus Eiswürfel machen!
Gebt einfach noch ein bisschen Minze dazu, frische Früchte.
Das Ganze dann zu Eiswürfeln verarbeiten und schon habt ihr das passende Getränk dazu!
Wie genial ist das denn bitte? So, euch jetzt noch ganz viel Freude beim Nachmachen.
Abonniert meinen Kanal komplett kostenlos damit ihr solch genialen Rezepte auch nicht mehr verpasst.
Und dann sehen wir uns beim nächsten Mal wieder auf Kikis Kitchen, Tschüss!